JED, OVER TO YOU.
WILL: THANKS, WILL.
SHE FOUGHT TO FLIP HER SEAT RED
AND TOMORROW NICOLE MALLIOTAKIS
WILL OFFICIALLY BE SWORN INTO
CONGRESS WHERE SHE WILL CAST HER
FIRST VOTE FOR HOUSE SPEAKER.
WITH A SLIM OPINION VICTORY CAN
NANCY PELOSI HOLD ON TO HER
GAVEL.
LET’S ASK NICOLE MALLIOTAKIS.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW AND
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU.
THIS IS A BIG DAY FOR YOU
TOMORROW GETTING SWORN.
IN WE WANT TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS
ON THAT AND A ALSO GET YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THIS NEW FOUND -- I
DON’T KNOW HOW MUCH NEW FOUND I
GUESS IT IS PUSH BACK ON NANCY
PELOSI AND WHETHER YOU THINK
THAT WILL GO ANYWHERE.
>> WELL, HAPPY NEW YEAR AND
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT LAST
TIME SHE WAS ELECTED SPEAKER
THERE ARE WERE 15 DEMOCRATS WHO
DID NOT VOTE FOR HER.
10 OF THOSE ARE RETURNING AND
THE MAJORITY IS LESS THAN THAT.
AND SO WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SEE A NEW SPEAKER AND WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR KEVIN McCARTHY
TO BECOME SPEAKER DEPENDING ON
HOW THINGS PLAY OUT.
REGARDLESS OF WHO IS SPEAKER
THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS TO
WORK TOGETHER TO SHUT OUT THE
SOCIALIST SQUAD.
THAT’S WHAT THE DEMOCRATS SHOULD
BE AIMING TO DO QUITE FRANKLY
BECAUSE THEY HAD SO MANY LOSSES
THIS YEAR.
THIS IS THEIR OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH US TO GET THINGS DONE
IN A BIPARTISAN MANNER.
JEDEDIAH: YOU KNOW, NICOLE, ONE
OF THE THINGS YOU HAVE BEEN
PASSIONATE ABOUT IS DEFENDING
POLICE, FIREFIGHTERS.
THAT’S ONE OF THE CHIEF REASONS
THAT YOU ACTUALLY WON KNOWING
HOW STATEN ISLAND VOTERS FELT
ABOUT THOSE ISSUES.
BUT YOU RECENTLY CALLED ON
GOVERNOR CUOMO AND MAYOR de
BLASIO IN THE FORM OF A LETTER
ACTUALLY TO PRIORITIZE THE NYPD
WHEN IT COMES TO GETTING THE
COVID-19 VACCINE.
HERE IS A SEGMENT OF THAT LETTER
WE HAVE HERE.
IT IS UNCONSCIONABLE TO THINK
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ARE
NOT CONSIDERED AT RISK ENOUGH TO
GET THE VACCINE IMMEDIATELY.
THE MEMBERS OF THE NYPD ARE ARE
FIRST RESPONDERS THEY HAVE
THOUSANDS OF CLOSE CONTACT
INTERACTIONS EVERY DAY.
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS OUR FRONT
LINE AND WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT THEM.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> RGTS OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
UNFORTUNATELY HAS TURNED THEIR
BACK ON OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WHETHER IT BE TO DEFUND THE
POLICE MOVEMENT, WHETHER IT BE
THE BAIL REFORM.
WHETHER IT BE CUOMO’S PAROLE
BOARD RELEASING 16 COP KILLERS
OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS.
WE ARE CONSTANTLY SEEING THEM
BEING DISRESPECTED BY OUR LOCAL
LEADERS.
I AT THIS POINT TO STAND WITH
NYPD AND I KNOW BECAUSE THEY ARE
THE FRONT LINE THEY CANNOT WORK
FROM HOME.
THEY ARE DEALING WITH PEOPLE ON
A REGULAR BASIS.
THEY NEED TO BE HIGH UP ON THIS
PRIORITY LIST.
AND IN FACT GOVERNOR CUOMOING
WITH UPPER THEM DOWN AND GIVE TO
INDIVIDUALS IN REHAB.
NUMBER ONE AN ISSUE OF GETTING
THE VACCINATION OUT AS YOU READ
THE OTHER DAY IN THE "NEW YORK
POST."
THEY HAVE THE VACCINATIONS NOT
ADMINISTERING THEM QUICKLY
ENOUGH AND NOT GETTING ANSWERS
FROM OUR MAYOR AND GOVERNOR AS
TO WHY.
JEDEDIAH: REACHED OUT TO THE
OFFICE OF GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO
AND MAYOR de BLASIO.
WE HAVE ARE NOT HEARD FROM THEM